[Musique]
c'est le calendrier c'est est ce qu'on
peut importe on peut remporter enfin
l'année en septembre octobre on a encore
des beaux jours
donc on peut reporter les mariages ou
est ce que ce sera pas possible parce
que il ya encore des restreinte au
niveau par exemple d'une monde a invité
ou autre donc voilà est-ce qu'on repart
en septembre octobre où est-ce qu'on
reporte en 2021
on a fait un petit sondage au sein de la
social pour connaître effectivement le
nombre de mariages qui va être reporté
sur 2021 on a estimé qu'il y avait
environ 30% des mariages 2020 qui était
déjà reporté en 2021 et pour nous en
fait s'il ya un manque à gagner parce
que du coup c'est 30% là ce sont des
mariages 2021 qui n'auront pas lieu en
enfin des coupes de 2021 qui vont pas
pouvoir se marier en 2021 c'est vraiment
un manque à gagner pour la profession et
pour l'industrie du mariage en général
est effectivement du coup c'est ça
complique un peu tout pendant sept
années 2020 on va avoir très peu de
rentrées d'argent
donc c'est comment est ce qu'on va vivre
pendant cette année là puisque si la
plupart des mariages sont reportés en
2021 c'est à dire qu'en 2020 notre
saison est vraiment computer donc
comment est ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on
peut vraiment vivre une année sans rien
est-ce que voilà est-ce que l'état va
être à la hauteur des aides qu'il promet
donc là pour l'instant on peut chacun
touché mais les 1500 euros de fonds de
solidarité mais on espère vraiment et
c'est pour ça qu'on a interpellé
bruno mais on espère vraiment que
c'était de la va se prolonger au delà du
mois de mai parce qu'en fait nous nous
on est on va vraiment être les derniers
à pouvoir redémarrer l'activité
donc on estime même que l'on va avoir
des incidences sur 2021
[Musique]
pour les couples qui n'ont pas d'eau et
dim kanner ça peut être effectivement de
se rapprocher d'un wedding planner pour
essayer de reprendre un peu en main
l'organisation peut être les accompagner
dans les autres dans les roues pas et
puis ça va être de patienter aussi de
prendre son mal en patience et puis de
rester à l écoute des annonces du
gouvernement